places kommt ran kommt allerhand kommen
halten
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen
zur viertel folge microsoft mutter es
geht weiter mit der epic storyworld und
es ist ein nach dem server könnte es der
denn es seien also für die leute bei mir
die sich jetzt wundern dass jetzt mehr
passiert ist ist das das kleine ab
wir hatten gerade eben eine kleine
aufnahme beziehungsweise ich ja wir
kommen rein und ganz erst mal ein steak
ich musste nämlich so besonderen kniff
machen aber sagt er hier wurde schon
gemacht oder nein er wurde noch nicht
gemacht echt nicht also meiner meinung
nach nicht ich weiß nicht genau ob die
das jetzt schon gemacht haben weil es
ist halt jetzt die dritte folge erst ich
mache erstmal waypoint web report nehmen
okay okay gut ob jetzt ein angreifer
damit wir dann wissen wo wir zu hause
sind aber ich glaube ich schau mal rein
ich habe da palmowski slate
seltsam weil die kisten sind leer
vielleicht ist er von einer durchgerannt
abgebaut
ich bin und jetzt online ändern warum
warum hat er sich weg gebracht hat ich
hätte jetzt so schön gesteht ich werte
das als taktik
du bist machst du auf apples smartphone
ist weg an richtern einfach einen kaktus
reich der mitte
der bosnier hat scheint schon
eingeleitet
ich habe ihm gesagt das ist das ist
dieser folge mehr alter auch hier attack
ist aber einfach wolle den geben können
ja ich halte einfach ein drittel spinne
jo-jo alter alter hallo alter waren
20.000 spinnen nämlich kein thema sagt
man nicht so gut und ohne scheiß brot
apfel
ja was ist einfach alles rote taschen
vielleicht dadurch um erstmal ins porno
abbauen
was kann ich dir das kann ich nie weg
packen raid storage wollen wir nicht und
jeder glas keine ahnung brauchen wir
glas nahe genug sand was sie machen
können
ja okay allerdings erst mal hoch sein
wie viel leben hast du
vier herzen extra der alte alter hut
richtig für die mobs alter schwede joel
vier waren das gerade dabei alles voll
ich habe jetzt 38 herzen extra geöffnet
man die history weizen alters weizen
ultra ultra geist auch was packe ich
jetzt weg
opel braucht wenn ich bei mir
marschordnung einsätze keine ahnung ich
bin über mit warum habe ich die
künstlich auf hallo wie die kunst ist es
eigentlich mit dem dungeon dieser tour
mir was geht der arbeiter weiter die
bank gewarnt dass entwickler alter hört
auf die kasse von der decke
runterzufallen das nicht geil alter opa
alter
wo kommt es her und es wird gleich recht
eng
ich hab nur noch spinnt sonst finde hier
ich bin da hier sind so viele coins auf
dem boden im turm und ich sage einfach
nicht mehr los ist
ich verstehe dass spinnen die wache ist
komisch die eine krasse sache
okay sagt attac ok ok komisch erfahrung
sammelt noch auf jetzt 36 level aber
links in wien nicht die kunst nicht wo
ich stehe ich da rein gehe ich habe erst
mal bisschen oder vielleicht kommt ihr
hintern versohlen ja ja die
familiengründung wasser auf diesen
leichenteile rutscht man irgendwie
komisch ab jetzt schon mal aufgefallen
systems deshalb wenn du einfach gartens
porno abbaus auf der spitze hat gebiss
und dann fällt wieder irgendwas von oben
runter so wie hier ja ja nein alter ok
ich muss jetzt nur aufpassen
ich habe nur noch für herzen dass ich
total
du musst sagen wenn du die musik im
hintergrund herstellern sagte massa ich
hoffe es kein problem richtig
anzusprechen abbau komplette chain
rüstung du brauchst eine rüstung noch ne
ja solche chaney mitnehmen oder so
einfach also die sagte irgendeine etage
darum kann er nee du kannst dir nehmen
und deine kiste packen alter alte geil
geil alter fit halte einfach bei uns
hier oben
miese zeiten habe ich zu viel wasser
immer dabei das darunter gehen kann
natürlich nicht
ihr könnt ihr übrigens in die kommentare
schreiben ob er ahnung habt warum die
münzen nicht aufgesammelt werden
ich weiß nicht ob 1556 münzen wie für
das du 600 vielleicht habe ich das
maximum auch schon erreicht könnt ihr in
die kommentare schreiben ich weiß dass
gar nicht auf jeden fall werden dass es
weitere dungeons suchen
heute will nun geh uns wo es einfach
nacht aufrecht legen jetzt ein
starfighter hatte der gar eine schaufel
dabei davon dass mir was gehen hier ab
weil diese action europa die radieschen
sind abwischen folge voll gewachsen
es kann keine lust hast du die mich
somit den kombi zombies herumzuschlagen
ich gehe jetzt erst mal schön geschlafen
hab ich mich auch hinlegen sonst kann
ich halte diese großen schatz muss
übrigens summe also ich bin im bett
heute ich musste noch in floskeln
geil 38 level jetzt es geht das geht
schon schon stramm schnell um unser geld
ok dann erstmal schlafen jetzt schon
wieder in fonds team muss ich auch noch
vor der wahl von unserem haus ist man
dieser typ der weiß nicht was ich gehört
ja geld ins wasser der schaden vor dem
frost krieg den wasserschaden [ __ ] logic
okay okay was ich es schaffen
13 jetzt schlafe nur ein ok ja leute
übrigens wenn ihr bock wer texture pack
macworld dann könnte das besser einen
kommentar schreiben
dann kümmere ich mich darum kann es hier
an bord nicht ob facebook ist meine
diamonds weiß ich meine damals doch
einfach einen automaten so statement
redstone alte rheinländer schartz
infiniti alter in findet müssen wir auf
dem bogen machen
da kann man glaube ich entlaste wochen
reinfallen kann endlos schießen ich weiß
gar nicht wo ich jetzt hingehen soll
wie lange menschen auf 110 minuten dabei
da können auf jeden fall noch hier ein
bisschen der kunden
wir können auch mal meinen gehen
das hatte ich es nicht auch ganz
spannend hier gibt es 1000 mineralien
und ärzte oder drüben ist ein haus ist 1
welches mit ihr über diesen roten ding
da so holz das ist ja aber da wohne ich
nicht mehr
also ihr könnt natürlich auch anfangen
uns ein haus zu bauen
vielleicht einfach hier oben drauf wäre
ich ganz lustig habe ich mal hab ich
noch dabei ist einfach mal holz
abzubauen als das was von meinem haus
ist das erz abbauen
ja das lohnt sich nicht dann musste ich
überlaufen
aber danke danke danke danke leute
wissen übrigens immer noch in der
vorbereitungsphase darf man nicht hin
das heißt das papier vp immer noch
abgestellt ist aber wir uns jetzt so
langsam auf die spannende phase
vorbereiten das heißt ein paar tagen
wird dann pvp freigeschaltet und dann
gibt es richtiges gebashe und ich glaube
wir sollten echt noch mal meinen gehen
business trip main oder so damit wir
noch ein paar lustige sachen kriegen mit
denen wir so was machen können
ich habe einfach weiter wie viele herzen
habe ich nun mal viele eltern gehen soll
oder dungeon noch einen anderen machen
sollen
da bin ich ein bisschen unentschieden
meinem leben ein bisschen reisen
ich wollte das haus machen mit dem haus
ich bin zwar nicht der meister bauer
aber oder nie wobei ich kann wirklich
nicht bauen lassen da schlief ich bin
eher so ausgestattet dass jetzt mal
wissen
ein bisschen pkw laufe einfach mal in
diese richtung betriebe werden gucken ob
da immer meine dunklen auftaucht
hey das ist alles bewegt sich einfach
übers ist schwarz hast du eine ahnung ob
sie so eine besondere lama gibt ja ich
hatte jetzt auch nicht vorher
anzusprechen alter wie zieht man hunde
mit knochen ich hätte meinen stack
gegeben es wird auch folgt im märz es
also ganz viele herzen ja lieb mich
folgt mir euer verfolgst du mir nicht wo
du undankbarer mal wie die türme auf der
minimap sieht sieht man warte ich kann
hier gibt's hier gibt es irgendwo eine
größere map also weißt du so eine große
web wo man reinschauen kann so eine
karte keine ahnung oder nur minimal die
richter dabei echt wie gesagt überhaupt
kein plan von dieser ganze wir schauen
auf uns und diese richtung gucken ob uns
da was tolles begegnet yahoo alter hpw
sprinten few voll vergab gomez laufen
laufen laufen laufen etwa ein bisschen
ins wasser ist eine wasser da drüben ist
eine hoffentlich war aber wären wir noch
nicht oder kann aber das macht also die
kommen nicht zu uns dieses 5000 blöcke
entfernt die dürfen auch gar nicht zu
uns glaube ich nicht gemacht
malte ist einfach places
alter meinte ich kann das schon hin
die bläser vom typ passt schon
also diese frost stecker versuchen 1 joh
vielleicht sollte ich doch mal komplett
darunter durch frost
walter nein diese places treffen die
ganze werde ich den fonds gehören will
jetzt gerade bewusst geworden wie
hässlich doch ja default ist nicht so
eine augenweide deswegen muss ich auch
mal eine möglichkeit finden da denkst du
denkst du implementieren
die hat 181 ruine also abbauen abbauen
okay aber geht ja noch weiter hoch
ich habe mich immer hoch kommen soll
auch eine lira
ein komischer kugelstoß handy kommt man
ja hoch das ist so ein kaputter tower
muss man sich hoch stecken oder wie eine
seltsam hast du den turm bei jetzt schon
vielleicht sollte ich jetzt ganz so oder
so direkt frontal auf die place drauf
rennen wer sie nicht so lud jetzt gehen
die places kommt ran kommt allerhand
kommt ein alter schlüssel das nein
niemals alters ist einfach alle bases im
ganzen turm runtergekommen rückfahrt und
die folgen mir jetzt auch du scheiße ach
du scheiße
ach du scheiße aber wenn ich in den wald
blogger kann ich den vergleich zu töten
muss hat erst mal regenerieren sagt
alter voll kriegt man einfach an der
oberfläche place trotz was sagst du bist
du eigentlich
mosen kabels rentenalter rennt rennt
rennt bitteren bitte alter zweieinhalb
herzen
jo alter diesen schon krass stark da das
sind wissen bestimmt 56 places alter
[ __ ] wo ich weiß nicht ob ich das machen
sondern alter war es nicht ich weiß echt
nicht ein spalt ich selbst ein schaf du
bist du alter das ist schon krass
andererseits die sporen hat auch die
ganze zeit neuner musste irgendwie
hochkommen man ist muss ein gericht aus
einer leiter dran machen wollen nicht
schon wieder die kassen
ob diese treffen
nur alter alter
gestorben feuerhexen kenner halten die
auch auf die kranken was dieses schwere
fälle kommen nur zwei hierzu places
das pony neu ich wollte um sind ewig
viele wieder hoch kommen soll
wir haben auch jetzt schon nach zehn
minuten aufgenommen ich glaube ich
überlege für die nächste folge von
meinestadt.de gibt
denn bei den chess places darauf kommt
wenn du sagen
darum sei jetzt erst mal keine
okay okay das war's alter also der
nächsten folge werde ich denke ich ein
bisschen meinen damit ich da so bis
laufzeit oder live ein bisschen
mineralien kommt also keine anreize oder
wie die ganzen eisen artigen substanzen
hier heißen und ich muss auch mal bei
den anderen rein schauen wie weit wir
schon sind was die so machen damit wir
nicht bissig hinterher hängen wie geht
es doch gut in unser bett da drüben so
groß wie bekommen wir ja vor sieben
blaze trotz bekommen das war ganz lustig
auch noch 50.000 charts zusammenstellen
wir schauen einfach mal tat dieser
geilen rüstungen die entrüstung ich mal
wissen
man braucht blue fires down und eis down
altern kann man einfach fliegen mit der
rüstung
kraft ja das ist diese rüstung von der
krise habe man braucht blue fires dort
vielleicht mal blut fest im leben
bekommt was könnte blue fire alles
machen alter alte blue fire
aber ich muss mich mal rausfinden wo
alles herkommt portale machen
ok krass ja gut das war ein ausblick auf
die auf die
kommen vorgehen so wie ich sagen dann
hab ich jetzt zu meinem bett und ja das
würde dann mal reinhauen also okay ich
lege mich pen macht's gut heute monster
monster aber sowas dann macht's gut
heute haut rein und scharf